/ ah bah tiens on va rester sur l'amour
mais on va tourner autour à ce sujet
pour vous car elle est en tout cas les
reporters du dimanche ont trouvé une
innovation qui pourrait peut-être vous
intéressez vous regardez vous dites que
vous en pensez puis vous aussi bien
évidemment saxe fex 17 américains qui
ajoute j'espère que ma femme aussi en a
envie mais je n'ose pas lui demander
je me suis déjà pris des râteaux et moi
j'attends qu'ils fassent le premier
parti sa femme une situation bloquée
donc c'est pour ça que ce couple inventé
un petit appareil ses deux boutons à
placer sur chaque table de chevet quand
l'un d'eux on a envie il appuie dessus
si l'autre appuyé à son tour sur le sien
les appareils vivre et et hop
sinon il ne se passe strictement rien
l'autre n'est même pas de courant et
peut regarder la télé tranquille en gros
c'est un team d'heure version domestique
un appareil pour éviter d'avoir à parler
de vive voix d'amour et de sexe alors
qu'est ce qu'on en pense alors j'ai
regardé je trouve chercher un petit
sondage dans les couples français ferait
selon leurs dires donc là c'est vraiment
du voilà du déclaratif l'amour en
moyenne entre 8 9 fois par mois voilà
est-ce que ces petits renault oui bah
écoutez moi je ne suis que le message
est un jeu donne les informations qu est
ce qu on en pense de ce petit bouton
m'appuie si l'autre appuyé en même temps
du coup on peut y aller enfin qu'est ce
qu'on en pense caroline d'abord alors
déjà sur les chiffres je pense que c'est
un mytho si on regarde non mais
franchement si on s'est quand même un
sujet dont on parle énormément de
manière intime quand on va prendre un
café machin avec des copines donc non il
ya très peu de couples qui font l'amour
deux à trois fois par semaine d'accord
il faut une fois par semaine et encore
je suis sympa donc déjà les chiffres ou
basse qu'elle arrêtait me regarder comme
ça parce que c'était désagréable
et pour ce qui est de ce petit bouton
au début je me suis dit aïe aïe aïe
pires idées et en fait je trouve que
c'est pas idiot parce que non mais oui
pas d'enfant en fait non mais attendez
ça crée un conflit dans le couple chaque
soir de savoir si l'un ou l'autre a
envie de faire un câlin ou pas il est
chaud mais quand je parle de manière
générale corps et goursat ça résonne une
fois que vous avez dit une fois j'ai mal
à la tête j'ai mal au ventre je suis
crevé en ce moment je suis stressé il
vous reste plus beaucoup d'exclus
d'accord donc vous allez devoir vous
confronter systématiquement à une
demande
enfin je parle de dans la frustration
c'est la même si vous avez appuyé sur le
bouton avec l'autre un peu appuyé willow
- au moins on se parle pas on se parle
pas
on met sur le tapis les problèmes tapie
avait ingéré voilà et on sait que ce
sera pas pour ce soir
ben c'est pas grave on lit un livre on
regarde un film et on se détend et à
vous revient alors déjà déjà on va se
calmer avec les excuses de la migraine
la migraine ces thérapeutiques mots me
trouver il suffit de faire l'amour pour
enlever la migraine
donc on va arrêter mais s'était excusé à
la cour d'accord on suit visiblement
doula beaucoup servi d'eux
et j'ai bien rit beaucoup de migraine
l'attendiez coûte d'ailleurs maintenant
portière du bouton porte l'aide du
bouton non franchement là c'est
l'absence du dialogue
alors on se perd le plus du tout c'est
fini lara tout vomi en discuter vaut
mieux dire bah pourquoi t'as plus envie
pourquoi ça fait ça fait une semaine
qu'on appelait au visage par un dialogue
franc bat évidemment quelques
informations il a plu pouplin encore
élevé mais qui est qui et le mec qui un
jour s'est dit tiens on va inventer un
bouton pour savoir si le machin image
alors le projet a été mis en financement
participatif vous savez les cagnottes
pour pouvoir le financer
et il a déjà atteint la somme souhaitée
avant la date limite
puisqu'ils ont demandé 6600 euros et là
c'est 16281 silence et à dire que des
événements ça répond à une attente les
gens sont venus en m'avoue j'ai mal pour
les couples de francky mais il ya plus
de dialogue il ya plus de voiles à de
petits rapprocheront sous la couette et
genre ça des vies et puis enfin nano
nanette c'est super des primes ciboure
qu'est ce qui se passe parce qu'elles
ont perdu leur âme d'enfant c'est un jeu
c'est ludique c'est un petit bouton
roule ça a été créé par un homme surtout
pour les hommes je vous la corde un truc
c'est que c'est simple c'est sans
émotion donc ça convient surtout aux
hommes parfois sans émotion pardonnez
moi mais on n'y parle justement
d'émotion ben non là c'est animal c'est
comme aller aux prostituées c'est oui je
défends le concept je suis pas sûr que
vous soyez le meilleur défenseur des
trucs de vous dire que c'est romantique
ou quoi que ce soit d'accord vous dit
que c'est c'est je veux tu veux tu veux
on y va baca et on repart bon eh bien
écoutez à ça vous a un peu plus
convaincus des terre-pleins on a posé la
question de téléspectateurs un bouton
pour faire l'amour dans le couple est ce
que c'est utile ou bien c'est n'importe
quoi
aïe aïe aïe c'est n'importe quoi pour
90% là-dessus caroline on ne vous a pas
écoutés pour rien en vous c'est votre
domaine
ça va toujours avoir